well if you're thinking about getting
your special someone a bouquet of
flowers today of course is a great day
for that local florists are busy this
morning as you can imagine for
valentine's day deliveries and hector
mejia is reporting live from a local
flower shop at desert inn in valley view
hector will there be enough flowers to
go around this year that's the big
question
there are but our flower shops have been
preparing for several months now just to
make sure they do have those flowers
good morning to you sherry so check out
these arrangements we have here we're at
miss daisy flowers uh local flower shop
here at di and valley view joining us
live we have jessica marshall owner so
tell us you know you are getting ready
to make so many deliveries today tell us
good morning good morning yes it's so
much fun to play cupid on valentine's
day we're making over 180 deliveries
already today and the day has barely
started so how does today compare to any
normal day yeah i would say we're
probably doing 10 times the amount of
business that we would normally do on
any given day so yeah we're prepared for
it so while you're playing cupid i'm
sure you've heard so many stories uh you
were telling us an interesting one about
a lamborghini can you tell us about that
yeah you know we have all different
kinds of fun clients but the florist
never tells but in this particular
scenario you know we do have some
clients that come in and love to clear
out our cooler and they'll literally buy
every stem that we have so it's always
fun when those things happen just how
many flowers were those it was over a
thousand roses that day
all right going back to valentine's day
tell us about the challenges you guys
had to you know overcome sure i mean
with the labor shortage and supply chain
issues we have been preparing for
valentine's day this year for a few
months now but i'm fairly confident that
we have enough red roses to be able to
supply the rest of the day's needs and
that is what people are asking for red
roses yeah red rose is a traditional
valentine's day flower i would say but
we do have all different kinds of
flowers of hydrangea anemones garden
roses we have some really nice stuff in
this year and lastly is it too late to
place an order it's not too late to
place an order but when we sell out we
sell out so i recommend getting your
orders in as early as possible awesome
thank you very much for your time so you
just heard it when they sell out they're
not to have any more so you'll want to
stop by early in the morning and snatch
those flowers before other people do
reporting live hector mejia live local
now